hey this is preshtowalker
simplify the square root of the quantity
three minus 2 root 2.
write your answer in the form a plus b
root 2 for real numbers a and b
this is said to be a Cambridge interview
question and it was covered by the great
Channel at blackpin RedPin
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
I'll get started by saying chat GPT
wasn't of any help at all because while
it provided another form of the
expression it was also still a sum of
square root expressions
so it didn't give us the answer
googlebard said this could not be
simplified
so so far we're out of luck so let's see
if we can solve it ourselves
we will set the square root of the
quantity three minus two root 2 to be
equal to a plus b root 2.
squaring both sides of the equation we
get 3 minus two root 2 is equal to the
square of a plus b root 2. we Square the
binomial to get a squared plus 2B
squared plus two a b square root of 2.
now we will equate 3 with a squared plus
2B squared and we will equate negative 2
with 2 a b
so we end up with two equations we have
a squared plus two B squared is equal to
three and two a b is equal to negative
two
so let's work through these equations
from 2ab is equal to negative two divide
both sides of the equation by 2 to get a
B is equal to negative one so B is equal
to negative 1 over a
we will substitute this into the other
equation to get a squared plus two times
the square of negative one over a is
equal to 3.
multiplying both sides of the equation
by a squared gives a to the power 4 plus
2 is equal to three a squared so then a
to the power 4 minus three a squared
plus two is equal to 0.
we can simplify this equation because
it's a quadratic in a squared
so this factors into a squared minus 2
multiplied by a squared minus one this
is equal to zero
we get a is equal to plus or minus
square root of 2 or a is equal to plus
or minus 1.
we now substitute that into B is equal
to minus one over a
so there are four pairs
so we have a b is equal to four
possibilities we have root two comma
negative root two over two
the next set will be negative root 2
comma root 2 over 2. then the third will
be one comma negative one and the fourth
is negative one comma one
now remember this is a plus b root 2. so
let's substitute in these values for a
and b
so we end up with the following four
results
but if you look closely
some of these are repeats so square root
of two minus one is the same thing as
minus one plus root two and minus root
two plus one is the same thing as one
minus row two so they're really only two
values we want to deal with
now we want the principal square root of
three minus two root 2 and that must be
greater than or equal to zero
but we know that negative root two plus
one is less than zero so we can
eliminate this possibility
therefore we know this simplifies to be
root 2 -1 and that's the answer
now that we know the answer we could
actually have seen a very quick way to
solve this problem
we could have written three as two plus
one then two is equal to the square of
root 2. so we had the square root 2 plus
the square root of 1 minus two root two
this can be factored into a perfect
square of the square of root 2 minus 1.
taking the square root and the principal
square root of both sides we would get
that the square root of three minus two
root 2 is equal to root 2 minus one so
it's a good way we could have solved it
but if you didn't know the trick it's
also good to know the long way to work
it out
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
foreign